- So nice to meet you Cole.
- [Cole] Nice to meet you.
- And, and also nice
to see you again, Lana.
- Great to see you.
Thanks for having us.
- Yes, we're very excited.
I, do you know Brian?
Did y'all know Brian before?
- Well, I just met.
Big fan.
- We just met.
- We just met indeed.
- Go way back?
Okay, so wait, you got engaged
since the last time I saw you.
- I did.
- [Kelly] You did.
I have secured the rock.
- I have secured the man.
- [Lana] Yes, and the man.
- I love it, I love it.
Wait, how did he propose?
Was it cool?
- It was awesome.
It was in, it was in, we were in Mexico
and he definitely surprised me.
And he put out this whole
little dinner on the balcony
and popped the question.
And then so random,
but Cole was like, he came to Mexico
and he was the first in,
a first human to see the ring
besides me.
- It was not random.
You invited my girlfriend and I.
- Well, so random.
He just showed up after I invited him.
- Don't act like I'm just
some drift that washes in.
- Also like what do you mean first human?
Who else did you saw?
- [Lana] It was me and Anthony.
- [Kelly] You know what? Alien.
- Right.
- Cole, was wildly unobservant.
Because I ran up to Cole
and I said, I said, Cole, look.
And he goes, you have nice nails.
(audience laughing)
- That's a dude.
- And I was like, Cole look.
- [Brian] Can I see the ring?
- Yeah, okay.
- [Brian] Oh, my God.
- I swear, I thought you were gonna say,
can I see the nails?
(Guests laughing)
- See, I'm trying to make
up for what Cole didn't do.
- [Kelly] That's amazing.
- I got you, I have you.
- So wait, let's talk about Moonshot.
I actually watched it.
I love it.
It's so, so cute.
I love, I don't feel like
rom-coms are really made anymore.
Like, like, I don't know.
I don't, I feel like
there's few and far between.
- Leave it to us.
- [Kelly] I love it.
I love it.
- Cover the market
- No, explain what it's about though.
It's so cute, it's so great.
- Well, it's about well, Cole.
- Wow.
- No, okay.
- So it's about-
- [Kelly] I can explain.
- We´re both, we're, I
play Sophie, he plays Walt
and we are stuck in a spaceship together
traveling to Mars to
be with our loved ones.
- Yeah, and he's been dying to go,
- He's been dying to go.
Me, not so much, but I
also love my boyfriend.
So I'm like, okay, here I go.
And then he basically assumes
my boyfriend's identity
'cause he is not legally
allowed to be on the ship.
But I sure am because my
character follows the rules.
His character does not.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- And then it's just all
about the crazy that happens.
- You're nailing it.
- Did I miss anything?
- Nope, that was every
single beat in the movie.
- I love it.
No, my favorite part
is when you're in the,
like, I don't know what it
is, luggage compartment?
I don't know where you're at,
but you have your little
like, I don't know, moment,
and it there, it's like,
there's like, what is it?
I don't know what's happening.
It's like something, like-
- It's CGI.
- No, yeah.
(Lana laughing)
- I'm also like,
you're ruining the movie
for everyone, Kelly.
- No, not CGI.
I know it's CGI.
I meant like, it just is really beautiful.
It's, all of a sudden it looks
like you're in some kind
of planetarium or something
like in the spaceship.
It's really, really cool.
- Thank you.
- Yeah, that was one of my favorite parts.
Um, so, whatever.
It's really cute, you're gonna love it.
So I have to ask.
So, what's going on with
season six of Riverdale?
- I don't know.
- You don't know?
(audience cheering)
(Cole laughing)
You're just in it.
- Yeah, you guys know about
as much as I do at this point.
- Do they really keep it that like tight?
Like the-
- Um, we don't know the ending yet.
But we get the scripts
probably about a week out of,
of filming the episodes.
So at this point,
I know that there's some
supernatural stuff going on.
And there's some superpowers.
Yeah, we did a five episode special
at the beginning of this
season, which was a lot of fun.
And I think some of those
themes are gonna be coming back.
I can't spoil too much.
- Yeah, oh you do know,
you're just not telling.
Fine whatever, Cole.
- Yes, I'm a paid actor.
(Kelly laughing)